يجب أن يُنظر إلى هذا القرار الذي اتخذته شركة tic-tock بالانسحاب من
هونغ كونغ على أنه جزء
من جهد رسائل أوسع من قبل شركة
tic-tock لمحاولة إبعاد نفسها عن
الصين على الرغم من حقيقة أنها مملوكة
لشركة bite Dance في بكين
لأن هونج كونج  في الواقع ليس سوقًا كبيرًا
على الإطلاق بالنسبة لـ tick tock ، فهو ليس
قريبًا من أي مكان على سبيل المثال الهند التي
حظرت مؤخرًا tick-tock من البلاد ولكن
ما يحاول Tick-tock القيام به هنا هو
إرسال رسالة إلى منتقديه
بأنه ليس في جيب
الحكومة الصينية هذا على الرغم من الدعوات من
أشخاص مثل وزير الخارجية الأمريكي مايك
بومبيو الذي وصف tick-tock بأنه تهديد أمني
بسبب القوانين في الصين التي
تتطلب من الشركات الصينية العمل مع
الحكومة الصينية عند سؤالها
وهذا جزء من سبب
قول مايك بومبيو إنهم  نحن في الواقع نفكر في
حظر tik-tok في الولايات المتحدة ،
فنحن نتعامل مع هذا بجدية بالغة ، ونحن
بالتأكيد نبحث في الأمر ، لقد عملنا على
هذه المشكلة بالذات لفترة طويلة سواء
كانت  مشاكل امتلاك
تقنية Huawei في البنية التحتية الخاصة بك ، لقد
ذهبنا إلى جميع أنحاء العالم ونحقق
تقدمًا حقيقيًا في تحقيق ذلك ، لقد
أعلنا أن ZTE يمثل خطرًا على
الأمن القومي الأمريكي ، لقد فعلنا كل
هذه الأشياء فيما يتعلق
بالتطبيقات الصينية على الأشخاص  الهواتف المحمولة يمكنني أن
أؤكد لكم أن الولايات المتحدة ستحصل على
هذا الهاتف بشكل صحيح - لكن tick-tock قد
أكد دائمًا أنه لم يحدث أبدًا
ولن يسلم أبدًا بيانات المستخدم إلى الحكومة الصينية
حتى لو طُلب منها ذلك وتأتي هذه الخطوة
في نفس الوقت مع بعض
أكبر منصات الإنترنت ووسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي في العالم بما في ذلك Google
Facebook whatsapp Twitter LinkedIn
وحتى Zoom قالوا إنهم
سيتوقفون عن معالجة طلبات بيانات المستخدم من
سلطات هونغ كونغ نتيجة
لقانون الأمن القومي هذا لأن
قانون الأمن القومي الجديد هذا  يمنح
شرطة هونغ كونغ سلطة مطالبة
هذه المنصات بتسليم بيانات المستخدم أو
إزالة المحتوى من
منصاتها التي تعتبرها السلطات
لخرق قانون الأمن القومي بطريقة ما ،
والذي يضع في الاعتبار يمكن أن يكون
شيئًا مثل الدعوة إلى استقلال هونغ كونغ ،
فعلى سبيل المثال ،
يقول فيسبوك إنه يريد التشاور مع
خبراء حقوق الإنسان قبل أن يتخذوا قرارًا
بشأن خطواتهم التالية للأمام.